Heath Ledger's brilliant oscar-winning
performance as the Joker in the Dark
Knight could have been just the
beginning in an interview with news
Australia the late actor's sister Kate
revealed that Ledger was incredibly
excited about his work with director
Christopher Nolan in The Dark Knight and
he was looking forward to playing the
iconic villain again in another movie
Cait admitted that the supposed demons
one critic described Ledger as having
didn't exist
she explained he was a really happy
person and he had huge plans for his
future he was so proud of what he had
done in the Dark Knight and I know he
had plans for another Batman movie he
just had the best time ever doing that
film when he came home at Christmas he
couldn't wait to tell us all about it
and he was doing the voice and laughing
showing me all the rushes we had a great
time Cate also mentioned that she spoke
with ledger the night before he died of
an accidental prescription drug overdose
and as she described it the siblings
spent time laughing and joking together
Ledger's unexpected death came On
January 22nd 2008 six months before the
Dark Knight arrived in theaters the
Australian actor was just 28 years old
at the time of his passing The Dark
Knight one of two of Ledger's posthumous
releases opened in theaters in July 2008
Ledger's turn as the deranged criminal
Joker redefined the iconic Batman
villain and impressed both fans and
critics alike he had delivered what went
on to be an oscar-winning performance as
one of these he comics his most famous
bad guys and he'd never be able to do it
again writing for The New Yorker critic
David Denby had only positive things to
say about Ledger saying it has one
startling and artful element the
sinister and frightening performance of
the late Heath Ledger as the psychotic
murderer the Joker that part of the
movie is upsetting to watch and in
retrospect both painful and stirring to
think about his performance is a heroic
unsettling final act this young actor
looked into the abyss a lasting but
totally unfounded consensus among fans
is that Ledger's performance as the
Joker may have contributed to his death
in one way or another which would
suggest that the experience was far more
traumatic than anyone knew and that he
wouldn't have wanted to revisit the
character if he got the opportunity
however according to the New York Times
ledger himself had said playing the
Joker was the most fun I've ever had or
probably ever will have playing a
character why serious filmmaker terry
gilliam who directed ledger in his final
performances Tony in the fantasy flick
The Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus also
shot down gossip about the late actor
telling the talks that the stories about
the Joker role making him unstable were
all hogwash
Gilliam said they were trying to imply
that plain the Joker had made him crazy
absolute nonsense Heath was so solid his
feet were on the ground and he was the
least neurotic person I've ever met
Heath was just great and that's why it
became so impossible to understand there
was none of this twisted neurosis that a
lot of actors suffer from cut I'll be
telling a joke about something else we
were packed at having fun again it seems
clear that ledger truly had an amazing
time playing Joker what isn't clear
however is whether Nolan had planned to
include ledger in 2012's The Dark Knight
Rises at the time Nolan wasn't even sure
that he himself would be back for a
third film as there wasn't an
overarching narrative in place yet if
ledger had lived to churn out another
Oscar caliber performance perhaps it
would have secured more Batman movies
for Nolan and an entirely different
future for the DC movie universe at
least fans will always have the Dark
Knight and Ledger's haunting embodiment
of the Joker to look back on what they
also have is more Joker heading to the
big screen as Joaquin Phoenix is
bringing the Clown Prince of Crime to
life and director Todd Phillips as Joker
set to hit theaters on October 4th 2019
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]